fdp chef christian lindner es uns jetzt
live zugeschaltet guten tag herr lindner
hallo guten tag wir hören es die
kanzlerin ist aufgeregt alarmiert sie
ist in sorge ist ihre sorge berechtigt
ihre meinung nach das müsste sie einmal
öffentlich darstellen auf der grundlage
welcher wissenschaftlicher fakten und
aufgrund welcher daten sie in
zusätzlicher neuer dramatischer sorge
ist wir hatten gerade eine sitzungswoche
des deutschen bundestages
da gab es eine regierungserklärung von
frau von herrn spahn frau merkel saß in
dieser debatte
parallel wurde im kanzleramt schon
gearbeitet jetzt an diesen neuen
verschärfungen an dem sogenannten egal
ob das muss man sich vorstellen
während der sitzung des bundestages sagt
die regierung nichts bereitet im
geheimen aber schon weitere
verschärfungen vor und der freitag als
sitzungstag der ist ganz abgesagt worden
heute tagt der bundestag hier nicht und
gleichzeitig laufen im kanzleramt
die drähte heiß wenn man für die nächste
woche drastisch zu freiheits
einschränkungen besprechen will
das ist eine missachtung des parlaments
und der öffentlichkeit gleichermaßen
erinnern sie sprechen über die geheimen
beratungen der kanzlerin was wir wissen
bei bild ist dass sie da eben immer auf
diese kurve aus irland verweist sowohl
sie als auch helge braun verweisen
darauf und sagen das darf in deutschland
eben nicht passieren ist diese kurve aus
irland aus ihrer sicht so eine warnung
dass weitere einschränkung berechtigt
sind
ich erinnere mich dass irland angel als
leuchtendes beispiel herangeführt worden
ist jetzt ist irland ein abschreckendes
beispiel oder dass wir irgendeine genaue
wissenschaftliche grundlage haben ob das
mit einer mutation zusammenhängt oder ob
das mit anderen sozialverhalten
zusammenhängt da sollte die regierung
darlegen auf der grundlage
wissenschaftlicher fakten
nachdem experten angehört worden sind zu
welchen schlussfolgerungen sie kommen
nicht alles was man vergleichen kann
trifft auch auf die deutsche lager zu
und neben der klaren darstellung auf
welcher wissenschaftlichen daten
grundlage wird entschieden
interessiert mich auch über welche
alternativen gesprochen wird
die regierung die das cdu-geführte
bundeskanzleramt ist immer sehr stark
und schnell wenn es um schließung und
feiert einschränkungen geht aber wie
handlungsunfähig haben wir uns erwiesen
seit monaten die besonders gefährdeten
menschen insbesondere betagte und
hochbetagte menschen menschen mit einer
behinderung oder vor erkrankungen zu
schützen
da passiert nichts da haben wir auch die
schweren krankheitsverläufe und
sterbefälle und ich will jetzt nicht
heute am tag als besserwisser erscheinen
deshalb weiß ich darauf hin dass wir die
fragen demokraten im parlament seit dem
spätsommer in jeder sitzung und bei
jeder gelegenheit darauf hinweisen und
das wurde immer barsch zurückgewiesen
also dann schutz der bedürftigen große
versäumnisse beim impfen haben wir
irgendwie versucht mit untätigkeit im
vergleich zu anderen ist irgendwie schon
zu managen schärfe und härte gibt es nur
wenn es darum geht die freiheit
einzuschränken
das stimmt von der balance nicht
sie haben die zahlen angesprochen am
anfang wie erklären sie sich dass wir
immer noch nicht wissen was eigentlich
silvester oder weihnachten in
deutschland in sachen corona passiert
ist und wie ist es zu erklären dass wir
nicht wissen was diese mutation wirklich
hier ausgelöst hat sind wir da irgendwie
nahm ein mittlerweile entwicklungsland
was daten angehen das heißt mittlerweile
wir haben seit langem größte defizite
bei der digitalisierung im öffentlichen
bereich herrnsheimer ich erinnere mal
daran dass die letzte krise die frau
merkel gemanagt hat die seinerzeitige
flüchtlingskrise auch enorme defizite
gezeigt hat bei der digitalisierung der
verwaltung viele menschen konnten mit
mehrfach identitäten einreisen oder
wurden gar nicht geprüft weil die
ausländerbehörden nicht vernetzt waren
das gleiche wiederholt sich jetzt im
gesundheitswesen da sollte bis ende des
jahres 2020 eine vernetzung der
gesundheitsämter eine digitalisierung
erfolgen
jetzt haben wir januar 2021 wird immer
noch mit dem fax gearbeitet so schweres
vorsorgen daran schuld ist dass die
kanzlerin sind dass die länder am ende
muss man da sein die fdp regiert auch in
einigen ländern mit unter anderem
rheinland pfalz und nordrhein westfalen
wieso haben sie da nicht zum beispiel
die dinger die die digitalisierung
verbessert das machen wir ja in
nordrhein westfalen gibt es in den
schulen eine beispiellose
digitalisierungs offensive im vergleich
zu allen ländern die größten
fortschritte
aber ich sag schon dass es ein
versäumnis der 15 jahre cdu geführten
bundesregierung ist dass wir in der
öffentlichen verwaltung so wenig digital
darstellen da stehen bei der letzten
bundestagswahl sind wir ja noch
belächelt worden was wir das thema
digitalisierung zu ernst genommen haben
jetzt sehen wir dass sie ein segen wäre
nicht nur in den schulen sondern auch in
der öffentlichen verwaltung selbst
konkret zu machen
2017 hatten wir angeregt ein bundes
digitalisierungs ministerium
einzurichten das tempo macht bei der
digitalisierung der öffentlichen
verwaltung damals hieß es mal nein das
brauchen wir nicht wir können das schon
anders bei der korona vanek und bei der
vernetzung der gesundheitsämter sieht
man jetzt wo wir stehen
herr lindner jetzt hören wir die
diskussion über weitere verschärfungen
einschränkungen beim öpnv home office
pflicht auch die fsb zwei masken pflicht
es im gespräch was halten sie von
solchen verschärfungen
die ffb zwei masken pflicht habe ich im
dezember selbst hier im bundestag einmal
angeregt eine masken pflicht fraglos
dann aber auch mit einer finanziellen
kompensationen der menschen etwa indem
man es bei der steuer absetzen kann oder
es kommt in den hartz-iv-regelsatz oder
die krankenkassen erstatten oder es wird
öffentliche ausgabe organisiert die auch
immer keine belastung für die menschen
aber eine solche masken pflicht mit den
wirklich wirksam masken die müsste ein
baustein einer öffnung strategie sein
denn der markus söder hat er jetzt diese
idee aufgegriffen und verlangt sie im
handel bei einer der ansteckungsrisiken
ausschließen will
im umkehrschluss kann man sagen wenn
eine solche maske gefordert wird dann
kann das auch ein baustein sein um
wieder auch andere
angebote über den
lebensmitteleinzelhandel genau ist sehr
kontrolliert zu öffnen
der bewerber um den cdu-vorsitz gericht
märz hatte sowas ja vergangenen woche in
der bild zeitung auch angeregt herr
lindner wenn wir jetzt auf die nächste
woche schauen das ist ja wieder
man kann sagen depressive woche die
dafür vor der tür steht am dienstag
geben die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
das kennen die deutschen mittlerweile
dann sitzen stundenlang dort die
ministerpräsidenten zusammen mal
streiten sie sich auch noch ein bisschen
dann gibt es die große pressekonferenz
und zumindest eine verlängerung und
möglicherweise eine verschärfung
was glauben sie wie lange halten die
deutschen das noch aus so man schaut aus
dem fenster ist es grau draußen und
denkt sich das kann doch nicht wahr sein
ja ich glaube dass unsere bevölkerung
sehr vernünftig und sehr diszipliniert
ist ausnahmen gibt es immer aber sehr
diszipliniert und wenn ich die umfragen
sehen herrnsheimer eine große zahl der
menschen ist ja der auffassung dass
diese regierungspolitik richtig ist ist
ja nicht so dass es in der mitte der
gesellschaft großen protest gibt ganz im
gegenteil wie viele e mails erhalte ich
ich möge doch mit der opposition etwas
leiser werden und sollte nicht immer die
regierungen dabei stören unsere
freiheiten einzuschränken
das war jetzt eben nötig also da sehe
ich viel weniger protestpotenzial als
andere klar es gibt a jugendtrainer
querdenker verschwörungstheoretiker das
aber nicht die große mehrzahl der
bevölkerung sagen ihnen aber trotzdem
dass wir weiter darauf drängen werden
selbst wenn wir da nicht in einer
mehrheit oder mit einer mehrheit der
bevölkerung argumentieren darauf drängen
dass die grundrechts einschränkungen nur
solange und soweit erfolgen wie es
notwendig ist und vor allen dingen
verlangen die respekt gegenüber der
öffentlichkeit und dem parlament
es kann doch nicht sein dass der
bundestag sich nicht mit der
verlängerung des lockdown zum acht bis
zehn wochen beschäftigt obwohl die bild
zeitung bereits darüber berichtet
das heißt also in der bild zeitung wird
diskutiert im parlament sagt die
regierung nichts dazu das geht so nicht
ich könnte ihnen jeden exklusiven
bericht das zeichnet sie ja auch aus
aber bitteschön danach muss die
regierung auch im parlament stellung
nehmen und nicht über gezielte
aktionen oder durch ihre guten
recherchen kommt es an die
öffentlichkeit und das parlament nach
außen vor bei soviel bild lo werden wir
jetzt fast ein bisschen rot herr lindner
aber ich möchte noch mal ganz konkret
ich möchte mal ganz konkret sozusagen
über die frage sprechen was man denn
jetzt tun sollte und sie haben ja
tatsächlich in den vergangenen monaten
immer wieder gesagt
der schutz der alten das muss fokussiert
werden da muss es verbesserungen geben
und jetzt erleben wir dass die kanzlerin
und auch die verteidigungsministerin
sagt naja also mehr bundeswehrsoldaten
können wir da eigentlich nicht
hinschicken warum schicken wir
eigentlich nicht unsere komplette armee
im roomster überspitzt zusagen vor die
altenheime um zu testen um zu helfen
wieso sind wir da so luftig und lustig
unterwegs also was sie mit laschet nein
und weiß ich jetzt vorfeld dieses
wochenendes nicht aber jedenfalls nicht
entschlossen genug
ich weiß nicht ob wird da überall die
bundeswehr brauche und dass man vorweg
zu schicken aber wir haben auch
freiwillige werben
medizinisch qualifiziert sind wir haben
auch laien die man kundig machen kann zu
mindestens um ein schnelltest anzuwenden
ich glaube das ist auch möglich ist dass
mehr medizinisches personal zb aus den
niedergelassenen arztpraxen impfen mit
gerade eingeblendet eingesetzt werden
könnte
das ist eine frage des willens und ich
füge hinzu wir werden auch sehr viel
mehr freiwillige beim impfen von
betagten und hochbetagten menschen
brauchen die sind nämlich oftmals ja zu
hause und in einer stationären
einrichtung und ich möchte eigentlich
nicht dass die auf die straße gehen oder
bus fahren zum impfen sondern dann
müsste eine aufsuchende impfmöglichkeit
geschaffen werden bei allen
schwierigkeiten mit den impfstoff in der
technischen handhabung
aber da ist viel zu wenig kreativität
viel zu wenig im besten wortsinne
unternehmerisches handeln der politik
probleme zu erkennen und dann kreativ zu
lösen mit knappen ressourcen wirksamer
umzugehen
es ist alles immer nur schließen und
dicht machen und gestalten sie einen
letzten satz weil sie auch regelmäßig
einblenden hier die inzidenz von 50
neuinfektionen pro 100
1000 einwohner ist eine rein politisch
gesetzte zahlen die ist damals ins
gesetz gekommen durch die cdu geführte
bundesregierung sie es ins gesetz
gekommen weil das die höhe von
infektionen pro 100000 einwohner in
einer stadt sein kann ob der mann noch
die infektionsketten nachvollziehen kann
diese das einer ganz kurzen ganz kurz da
das ist ja wichtig auch für die
zuschauer
und sie kennen sich da aus wissen sie
wieder wieder diese zahl dann am ende
entstanden ist hat helge braun der
kanzleramtschef gewürfelt oder die
kanzlerin ob sie auf 50 oder 75 oder 100
nicht gewürfelt aber diese zahl wird
angenommen dass sei die zahl von
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner die
unseren gesundheitsbehörden in der lage
sind nachzuverfolgen das was da kann man
auch fragen mit wem waren sie zusammen
gehen haben sie getroffen
bei 50 diese zahl spiegelt aber
offensichtlich nur die
personalausstattung und die technischen
möglichkeiten der gesundheitsbehörde
während die besser ausgestattet da
können wir vielleicht ihre
bundeswehrsoldaten auch noch stärker
einbringen während die personell besser
ausgestattet während den digitalisiert
dann wäre die zahl vielleicht 75 oder
sie wäre vielleicht 80 und wenn sie
schlechter ausgestattet werden nur 20
das heißt an dieser einen zahl macht man
alles fest frau merkel macht daran alles
fest und das halte ich für falsch
wir müssen auch zum beispiel die
situation in der intensivmedizin mit
berücksichtigen wir müssen uns fragen
wer ist infiziert ist ein großer
unterschied ob es ein plötzliches
infektionsgeschehen in einen würde das
schon hatten fleischverarbeitenden
betrieb oder in einem alten hansmann was
ist ein pflaster oder ob es bereits
gestreut ist also nur die orientierung
an dieser anzahl würde dazu führen dass
nach meiner prognose wir bis ostern aus
der schließung nicht rauskommen und das
kann es glaube ich nicht sein da geht
selbst die größte volkswirtschaft da
geht auch die viertgrößte
volkswirtschaft die wir sind die gegner
in die knie
unternehmer sie haben es gerade eben
schon angesprochen die deutsche
impfstrategie was ist denn ihrer meinung
nach schiefgelaufenen gehören ja immer
wieder wir haben ausreichend impfstoff
aber es dauert einfach zu lange wir
haben ja gerade mal ein prozent der
bevölkerung geimpft
offensichtlich ist
wenig rechtzeitig bestellt worden die
jetzt bestellte menge reicht vielleicht
mit blick auf das jahr 2021 aus aber es
haben eben andere schneller und besser
intelligenter beschafft und deshalb
werden die jetzt früher versorgt es ist
richtig dass auf europäischer ebene zu
organisieren nur darauf verweist die
bundesregierung immer wieder
allerdings hatten wir ja die eu
ratspräsidentschaft in der zweiten
jahreshälfte 2020 der deutsche
gesundheitsminister war der vorsitzende
der europäischen gesundheitsminister
konferenz die kommissionspräsident sind
es eine deutsche cdu-politikerin also
sozusagen in europa ist vielleicht etwas
nicht gut gelaufen das verweist immer
wieder auf die deutsche bundesregierung
zurück aber wie gesagt nicht immer nur
so als kritiker erscheinen und
konstruktiv einen vorschlag machen
wir brauchen jetzt einen impf gipfel da
müssen alle an den tisch pharmazeutische
industrie niedergelassene ärztin und
ärzte freie wohlfahrtspflege alle müssen
die gemeinden natürlich die die
impfzentren organisieren landkreise die
müssen an einem tischen überlegen was
können wir tun damit das besser wird und
ich glaube dass wir auch noch nicht alle
möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft haben unserer
pharmazeutischen industrie
natürlich dauert es lange einen neuen
produktionsstandort zu eröffnen aber
jeden monat jede woche jeden tag den wir
schneller beim impfen werden weil er
jetzt die produktion ausweiten
der schützt menschen leben und der
schützt schützt auch unsere
wirtschaftliche basis
man wird nicht von jetzt auf gleich die
produktion deutlich erhöhen
aber wenn frau merkel davon spricht dass
wir erst im zweiten halbjahr 2021
hinreichende fortschritte bei der
versorgung erreichen
da glaube ich können der einige monate
sparen wenn wir jetzt ganz entschieden
mit der pharmazeutischen industrie
überlegen was kann man tun um ein paar
wochen schneller zu werden
danke schön herr lindner dass er sich
heute die zeit genommen haben ich danke
ihnen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei welt schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergessen nichts abonnieren